herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
leute ich habe heute immer wieder etwas
in den weiten des internets gefunden und
zwar eine folie die verspricht sachen
unsichtbar zu machen
jetzt denkt ihr euch vielleicht so ok
klappt ähnlich aber wenn dann ist das
richtig teuer
wir haben 90 cent gekostet ich bin
jeweils bei luca da hätten wir das ganze
auf treffen sogar hinter der kamera und
dass das paket mainz 90 cent inklusive
verantworten muss halt überlegen beim
anschluss der versand allein schon fünf
euro knopf darf es kommen natürlich
versteht dass er nicht wie können kann
es mir nicht erklären den konzernen wie
können sachen kommen wird
versandkostenfrei kommen auch weil china
shops sowie geht das feld weil die
vitamine und dann sind sie sportlich
sind die tragen dass ihre namen sich aus
herford machen okay wir machen das paket
ist einfach mal auf man muss sagen es
ist wirklich keine scheiße
ich hoffe es ich weiß eigentlich ganz
genau ob das funktionieren wird aber ist
eigentlich so ein zauberei hat das ding
sowieso einen zauberstab ist also wir
machen das ganze mal auf und irgendwie
sehen die sachen bei denen das er
sichtbar aus komisches gefühl irgendwie
egal ist dass ich dachte ist das wäre
richtig viel folie einfach ok alles eine
frage der zeit gibt keine studien
verfahren das hier jetzt mal ganz im
ernst also man sieht sich dahinter nicht
aber ja aber man also was das eigentlich
können soll es einen stift aber not oder
halt der verkauf wird davon
das ist nicht extra ich mag nicht
schreibt er trotz dem nein der ist nicht
nur unsichtbar auf die schriften von
anderen stift
er wollte aber ich probiere das jetzt
mal ich hab nämlich angeschaut wie das
funktionieren soll und angeblich
funktioniert ist in eine richtung so ist
es da oder fett weg ist ist weg
ich meine es todernst zu mir ja aber ich
glaube einfach dass das hier einfach das
ist aber je weiter ich weggehe desto
mehr sieht man davon nicht ab und
dreimal ich hole das wird vertikal steht
so sicher
jetzt funktioniert es richtig ist
ungehalten gott fahrzeug so sieht man es
wirklich die ganze zeit wenn man so
dreht hoher warte hier kann der nach
seiner so geht so dass so nah
[Musik]
genau so funktioniert das wirklich okay
ich zeige dir etwas richtig kracht es ja
wenn das funktioniert hat dann
funktioniert das ist alltag von jungen
leute verschwinden einfach kompletten
wenn ich das drehe versteht die andere
alltag
was mach ich das nicht missverständlich
also wird irgendwie bei diesen linien
das hat richtig gut geklappt oder wenn
ich sowas und so hat er doch froh mein
gott das ist echt über krass und dann
ist als dreher wurde gern in den pal in
welcher das vor die wand
überhaupt versteht man nur seiner deine
hand warum die andere unter ich meine es
ernst das ist über kraft jetzt macht
wieder was andere hand rein das ist echt
krass
du musst ja das länger selbst anschauen
ich bin fingerzeige schreibt kommentare
der redlichen finger von den exporten
linien von den tories muster auf den bau
also wieder ein weiterer fall fand was
trinken danach ziemlich diese karte und
ich möchte also die sache jetzt jetzt
gerade sie ist einfach eine bombe aber
wenn man jetzt hilfe sinnvoll gestreckt
es ist krass
die karte passt sich irgendwie diesen
dessen farben darüber wo man also die
meisten fahren aber irgendwie viel zu
wenig jedenfalls wird ja schon ist es
passiert ein bisschen bin ich weg bin
ich was ich gehe mal hier und hat dabei
die wahl mehr haben bin ich direkt hier
zwischen ich bin jetzt ein bisschen der
anteil verdient systems hervor zu dem
gemacht habt was auf den kopf gemacht
haben sie schon krass einmal vielleicht
hat in unserem land das andere talent
ich war auch 1934 und las vegas auch
beruflich nebenberuflichen agieren
also man ja das ist schuld wenn man das
geld einmal drüber alles verschwindet
wir rechnen labels at des kopfes mit
warum das ist meine mutter war das
wirklich so ist das halt ich spüre hier
wieder was ist 3d karte jetzt von meinem
kopf nicht so lange würde ich auch
regiert ich habe ein video angeschaut
was das ganze erklärt und das hat mit
diesem effekt hier zu tun wenn man zum
beispiel vor seinem kühlschrank mit
gebürstetem stahl eine lichtquelle
dann zieht das licht so sieht er aus wie
so eine ebene das kennt man ja auch von
so sonnenuntergänge über mehr so dass es
so ein strich hat und das egal wie man
es dreht und egal aus welchem winkel das
licht auftritt
hast du hier keine fälle treten also es
ist immer eine ebene wenn das licht teil
quasi zurückgeworfen wird
dann wird alles entlang einer richtung
verzogen das heißt wenn man halt
vorsichtig ist sowie strich sind ich
stehe nur noch auf dem strich ja dann
ist man einfach weg alter doch wie
schwöre bei gott es sind gerade heftig
aus weil da ist ein bisschen weiß und
das ist grau unternimmt die beiden
linien mit rein
heute schaut euch das an ich hab mir
leute guckt euch das an das ist gerade
das aller heftigste will ich weg einfach
dein kopf ist einfach komplett weg wenn
ich so was dann gekommen wenn ich das
ding doch für heute eine parallele hand
dahin okay aber dann musste ich so ein
bisschen so wenn ich so mache
beispielsweise dann kann also davon
erkennen aber wenn ich jetzt guckt euch
das mal leute wo hat wartet mit ich hab
ich habe den leuten machen wir den kopf
genau davor die noch vor mein gott
ok neutras und man muss ein bisschen
mein gott mein ich bereit hier gehört in
schwerstarbeit ein szenario vor
dieser stift hier noch könnt ihr sehen
die frage ist warum das habe ich noch
gar nicht raus punkt warum ist der
stiftung auch dabei gewesen ich glaube
eigentlich gute frage
die sechs nicht wahrscheinlich um linien
zu zeichnen oder dem verschwinden zu
lassen dass hier was man aus
deshalb stift und erst noch in hand mit
stift kein problem
doch mal habt ihr das abonnierte
entertainment oder nicht stelle ich mir
vor die weise daran den laden passt das
nicht dass die naju dreht jetzt nicht
vor ihnen einer wand die wir da hinten
beispielsweise komplett voneinander
gegenstand sondern die wand des wegs
sehr unruhig sag ich mal
und sie hat eigentlich primär so linien
ja deshalb war ich halt nicht so gut wie
jetzt relativ unruhig ist bin ich wieder
weg
das teilprojekt hayes kraft das so
komisch wie diese schrecken heute ganz
aber diese folien probieren das so aus
und spielt damit rum das ist bestimmt
jetzt unbemerkt das hier ist oder nicht
leute also jetzt kein scheiß irritiert
es ja selber gerade das gras als krasse
ist er passt sich immer den in den
kombinierenden umgebung also machen wir
erstmal was ich gerade mache ich noch
gar nicht
willst du machen willst du diese die
waagerechten linien entfernen ja stimmt
der chef kommt man da von deinen kopf
fit ist ist aber keinen kopf mehr um ein
dort was der folie macht unsichtbar
stelle ich mal seit seitlich gegen zwei
spieler hinein kapuzen pulli zur hälfte
wurde kann jetzt verstehen
[Musik]
da bin ich jetzt bin ich weg da bin ich
jetzt mit meinen spaß leute das war's
von heutige video wir haben einfach ein
bisschen damit rumgespielt manche das
glaube ich wenn man die perfekten
bedingungen schafft mit einem
hintergrund- und so weiter und sofort
kann das richtig richtig gut aussehen
aber es ist auf jeden fall echt
interessant und werden noch nicht zu dem
auch mal überlegen was man so was
eigentlich wenn die technik wissen
ausgefeilter ist alles benutzen kann
ebenso alt gerade in militär- oder
sobald du kannst einfach menschen
verschwinden lassen
gerade dort größere distanz mega heftig
für 90 cent auf jeden fall meinen grünen
der brauchen wir sie jetzt von diesem
video wieder kommt auch bei dunkler
vorbei da wir auch ein video gedreht
[Musik]